welcome to this video playing
international master RF I had district
of eight this is one of those that's
Egypt enough yeah there they are all
awfully similar but very hard to tell
apart at least for me the nums oh yeah
let's play a free just like on earth did
in them what championship match and I
had recommended the sermon some time ago
in my series after castles n e4 as a bit
questionable you to d5 so a3 is doing to
go form leading to the samish
interesting so investing time yeah but
should be seven seems a bit passive to
me but okay it's probably probably still
playable play loans um so II 5 i'm not
sure if i should trade first okay but
let's let's play five immediately yeah
he can go to v8 keep d 5 cover but yet
looks like a miserable square 97 is the
better move now if i take twice on d5
you'll play c5 and open up the center
mmm still it's not so clear and that
this is so sufficient for black
hmm besides tempting tempting to grab
that okay but let's both of the center
first not falling too far beyond and
developments ed ed 95 probably see five
and then now I'm really clearly behind
in development yes this is what I have
expected the question is how to play now
I can I can consider d5 this might be
good might be six though we should lay
two takes and I tags this is a good line
it could be good for word okay so you
will play Knight b6 the tempting thing
about this line is that i might get a
good piece all night d 5 there should be
six or so good with him yeah that's
that's true hmm mighty sound check young
problem check yeah he's ok now i have a
hard time to to keep the bishop Ian yeah
and I'm not very well developed ok so
default was it was good but pretty off
to sleep now okay we go here me so that
I maybe have Bishop e3 with the temple
and I q5 might also be an idea the
energy five this is a threat him ok but
it's not really doing much good no just
every caption and I to aveda this is
really massive down I'm trying to use
this how to have six I it's got Quinn d3
this might be that the idea ok he goes
queen bee three now I can't take on c5
on I can take on c5 why not still have
the rook attack taking a serve as tool
it's not forceful enough I can also go
to f2 instead of taking now you can take
a five anyway if i go to the high-tech
c5 is playing look see 80 ok let's take
that first ok it's not doing any of that
just playing the song ok
I only have this vulnerable piece on a
to empirically to address some what it's
uncovered and not really co-ordinated
well with the rest of the pieces and f6
if he takes I go f6 threatening f7 and I
need to ready to open up the position on
I forgot about that nice bra that's
embarrassing
ah what the heck I forgot about that
moon check yeah i just bought an
excellent position to nothing if at all
I mean maybe I Brewers yeah probably not
but I was I had a really good position
before with h6 is a very strange move
just weakens the Kings side don't don't
really understand okay this is not a bad
piece on and on c3
I've got the bishop on c3 and the Queen
on g3 or yet towards g7 would be very
nice if I get the Knight to f5 join join
the attack can i play can i play night
h4 now come on he plays night before I
can take it and play night at five this
is at least danger person
yeah I probably can play Queen g602
defenders yeah unfortunately this is the
best I can do the position is about
equal but I have no time
sorry as the leftist nasty cold it's a
bit better but not all right not
completely completely done with time
warning
check yeah it's you you got the apron
I'm still very active though I don't
think girl with a normal time
distribution I should lose the game
check
g4 g5g six and a meeting but that's not
going to happen and not quite sure what
he's doing check
check-check just a draw basically check
check check no it's not check black
forfeits on time wow what the heck yeah
this was a really bad game yeah this was
some the first game without any warmer
benched whatsoever wrong Tia I really
felt good about my position but then
something wrong was simply it was simply
happening oh yeah he had a good move
computer through Schloss as usual before
before it's a strong booth yeah this is
this is really nice it's basically a
double attack Lucas detect already and
now the power as well so this is very
nice for white k and around here I
probably should just play m6 should give
me some edge at least on the porn up and
I have this technique chances this was
looking nicely but it's just it's just
not good giving away the pawn I forgot
about that possibility simply okay and
now he drove my bishop to learn to c3
which really looked noise computer now
wants to take on a sadness awfully
materialistic but probably good young
yeah okay I was looking at the kingside
more I thought that this would be him be
more promising but it's really a it's
really not after that is just ok Ferb
like the TM he could have played the
rooks III awesome
ya hear this is completely equal but can
he manage to get sir oh he's got 93 wow
what a bad game what he took on c3 um
and okay now we got to the rook endgame
check the only slightly interesting
decision was around here when I think
it's already a draw like has no real way
to to improve the position I don't don't
see anything at least she's a he managed
to check to school to jab work into a
major after that and so it's made check
the only had one second on the clock but
this was really a crap game I hope you
enjoyed it anyway widow who finally no
no comments